hello everyone and welcome to today's
live webinar how to use curse bear cash
9 for knockout knockin and gene
activation presented by amanda haas
product manager at horizon discovery i
am mayor and mayor gross at horizon
discovery and I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's educational web
seminar is brought to you by lab roots
and sponsored by horizon discovery
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you
would like at any time during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box located at
the far left of your screen and click on
the send button will save several
questions for Amanda to answer during
the Q&A session additionally we have a
technical support scientist standing by
to answer questions as they come in
during the presentation we will answer
as many questions as we can if there are
questions that don't get answered during
the presentation we will send an email
response in the coming days
also please notice that you will be
viewing the presentation in the slide
window to enlarge the window click on
the - arrow symbol at the top right hand
corner of the slide window
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the support tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem through the ask a question box
continuing educational credits are
offered for attending this webinar
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
I would now like to introduce our
presenter amanda haas she is a product
manager at horizon discovery amanda
joins dharmic on now horizon discovery
in 2005 and has worked in multiple
departments including manufacturing
chemistry biology R&D and product
management currently she is responsible
for custom synthetic manufacturing and
cast 9 nucleus products throughout her
time here she has contributed to
research projects and new product
development in multiple areas across RNA
interference and CRISPR cast 9 genome
engineering Amanda received her degree
in chemistry at the University of Miami
in 2003 now let's get started
Amanda I'll now hand the reins over to
you
thank you for that introduction and
thank you for joining us for today's
webinar I am excited to talk to you
about considerations and reagent
selection for using crisper cast 9 in
several different applications
as a quick overview I will walk through
some background on crisper cast 9 gene
editing and then gives some
considerations that are important in
guide RNA design next we will look at
several different applications using
CRISPR for knockout knock in and
transcriptional gene activation as a
reminder if any questions come up during
this presentation please feel free to
use the ask a question button to send
your questions in
first I'm going to give a brief
introduction to crisper cast 9 so that
we will all be on the same page about
how the system works so what are crisper
cast systems
crisper casts as a term originated in
2002 to describe the bacterial immunity
system evolved to defend against genetic
parasites CRISPR stands for clustered
regularly interspaced short palindromic
repeats and casts stands for CRISPR
associated proteins so why do bacteria
need this system bacteria need an
adaptable immune system to generate
resistant mutants because phases
outnumber and evolve much faster than
bacteria the way this works is that the
bacteria acquire foreign DNA from any
invading substance then they integrate
this into their own genome at a specific
CRISPR locus the bacteria expressed the
integrated foreign DNA sequences as
guide CRISPR RNAs that can interact with
the cast proteins to cause interference
of any incoming viral or plasmid
activity by cleaving complementary
sequences through this mechanism
bacteria can eliminate foreign invading
substances that are like things that
they have encountered in the past
9 was adapted for use in mammalian
genome editing by introducing the
bacterial system into mammalian cells
the native s pyogenes system shown on
the left consists of a cast 9 protein
and 2 rnas the crisper RNA and tracer
RNA additionally you can use a chimeric
single guide RNA or sgrna as shown here
on the right where the crisper RNA and
tracer RNA are linked into a single
molecule when the system is delivered or
expressed in mammalian cells it can
cause a double strand break
resulting double-strand break can then
be repaired by endogenous mammalian
repair mechanisms two of the major
pathways in mammalian cells for such
repair are non-homologous end joining or
nhej a and homology directed repair or
HDR nhej a can result in several
outcomes including repair to wild-type
insertions or deletions known as indels
these in dolls can create a frameshift
mutation or premature stop codon which
result in functional gene knockout on
the other hand HDR is used for precise
genome engineering such as inserting a
point mutation or generating a knockin
it requires a donor DNA template for
repair of the double-stranded break HDR
typically has lower overall efficiency
compared to nhej a but can result in a
precise genomic edit
even though crisper cast 9 is a
relatively new technology there have
already been thousands of publications
the rapid development of this technology
has quickly expanded its scope into
disease treatment and personalized
medicine and new applications are being
found every day it is an incredibly
exciting time to be working in this
field and there is huge potential for
the future
before we get into the details of CRISPR
applications I want to discuss
considerations for guide RNA design and
the impact they can have on all CRISPR
cast 9 experiments
the two aspects of guide RNA design to
be considered our functionality or how
efficient the guide is at creating a
double-stranded break and specificity
what is the guides potential for causing
a break in unintended regions of the
genome I am going to walk you through
our development of an algorithm for
functionality and then show you data
from experiments we did looking at guide
RNA specificity to minimize off
targeting
so we set out to answer the question of
whether design is important for
functionality or whether most crisper
guide RNAs will just work we performed
an arrayed screen testing over 1,100
guide RNA designs spanning 10 genes
resulting in not just cutting but a
functional read out with a phenotypic
reporter assay on the right is the data
for one of the genes plotted where the
vertical axis represents functionality
from low to high and the x-axis is every
crispr RNA in this genes coding region
as you can see there's quite a bit of
variability in functionality along the
coding region if we look at the CRISPR
rnase by the arrows I've drawn on the
top data set we see very different
functionality for two crispers that are
right next to each other and there are
many highly functional crispers in the
late exons shown in the circle drawn on
the bottom data set the data indicate
that not all crispers are equivalent and
the conventional wisdom of always target
in an early exon is also not accurate we
then use the quantitative knockout data
from these ten genes to train an
algorithm for functionality
after the algorithm was designed we
tested it in multiple assays here I'm
going to show you one example of that
validation we performed an experiment in
a different cell line than what was used
for the algorithm development with 10
completely different genes that then
were used for the training data set
based on the algorithm predictions we
picked the top 10 high-scoring CRISPR
RNAs and the 10 lowest scoring CRISPR
RNAs for each gene
these were transfected into HEK 293
t-cells that Stavely Express caste 9
after 3 days amplicons were generated
for each target sequence in the edited
cells as well as untreated cells these
were indexed and pooled for NGS analysis
and the percent perfect reads of the
edited cells were compared to that of
the untreated cells
what we found is that high-scoring
CRISPR rnase shown on the top graph 93%
of them had greater than 40% in del
formation while only 33% of the low
scoring CRISPR rnase had more than 40%
editing efficiency which is shown on the
bottom graph this demonstrates that
CRISPR RNAs
with high functionality scores overall
have higher cutting efficiency these
data show us very convincingly that our
criteria for selecting highly functional
guide RNAs has much improved performance
over guides that were selected without
these criteria
the next can
that we wanted to evaluate with guide
RNA specificity it won't do any good to
have a highly functional guide RNA if it
also happens to cut multiple regions of
the genome so we need to ensure that the
guide RNA doesn't have perfect matches
to anything but the target gene we
performed and published a systematic
study looking at the tolerance of
mismatches when introduced at every
position along the crispr RNA let's look
at these experiments and some general
conclusions first I want to call your
attention to the diagram at the bottom
of the slide here we are depicting
genomic DNA with a pam site being
targeted by a guide RNA which is shown
in green in the guide RNA position 1 is
the 5 prime most base of the crispr RNA
and position 20 is adjacent to the pam
site because we can easily make
synthetic CRISPR RNAs we were able to do
a systematic and comprehensive study of
all of the 1 and 2 base mismatches for
two different genes vcp and PSM d7 we
use the proteasome assay for a
functional GFP readout when GFP
expression is high the indicated target
gene is being knocked out shown in the
graph are the result of a one base
mismatch being walked along the 20 base
guide RNA sequence as you can see when
normalized to the perfect match guide
RNA which is the red dot for both genes
there is generally a decrease in
functionality as the mismatch approaches
the 3 prime end of the targeting
sequence mismatches in positions 11
through 20 of the guide RNA
result in a complete loss of
functionality we also noted that single
mismatches at the 5 prime end of the
target region are generally tolerated
and retained some level of functionality
here are the results for vcp with a
two-base mismatch walk again with our
GFP assay similar to the graph on the
last slide the y-axis represents
functionality and the x-axis is all of
the different combinations of two base
mismatches for the guide RNA the data
was then sorted from sorted sorry from
highest to lowest functionality with two
mismatches we found that less than 5% of
the combinations tested retained
functionality and the combinations that
did retain functionality usually
included one of the mismatches being at
position one which as a reminder is the
5-prime most base on the guide RNA we
had to zoom in on the graph to see the
few sequences that tolerated two
mismatches which was only seven of the
hundred and ninety sequences tested over
all these data tell us that we need to
avoid guide RNAs with one or two
mismatches to other regions of the
genome to reduce off targeting
so here's a quick summary of the data
that I've shown on the previous slides
for generating a highly functional
algorithm and important considerations
for guide RNA specificity we combine
these data to generate the editor
algorithm which considers both
functionality and specificity and is
used in designing all of our
pre-designed products
so now that we're all on the same page
let's dive into some applications first
let's look at gene knockout
I will walk through several applications
using gene knockout I will show examples
of knockout for protein coding genes
non-coding RNA and an example of
knockout in IPS cells for knockout we
are relying on the cell's error-prone
endogenous repair mechanism
non-homologous end joining here the
double strand break is introduced by the
cast 9 nucleus and the endogenous repair
results in a population of cells with
various endo like I mentioned earlier
some of these in indels will introduce
premature stop codons or frameshift
mutations that will result in protein
knockout
here is the experimental workflow for
using crisper cast nine for gene
knockout we need two components the cast
nine nucleus and the guide RNA for these
two components there are many different
formats available for cast nine
there are Lenti viral particles plasmid
protein and mRNA for the guide RNA
options include synthetic crispr RNA and
tracer RNA synthetic single guide RNA
lentiviral single guide particles or
lentiviral single guide plasmids the
workflow in the middle of the slide
demonstrates how to create gene
knockouts cells are transfected with
cast 9 nucleus and guide RNA
at this point several techniques can be
performed including clonal isolation or
antibiotic selection and then detection
and characterization can be done by PCR
based mismatch detection Sanger
sequencing Western blotting or using a
phenotypic assay
here is an example of a clonal isolation
and expansion workflow starting with the
caste 9 and guide RNA source cells are
transfected or transduced and then
sorted or diluted to obtain a single
cell per well these single colonies are
then grown for a period of time until
there is a large enough population for
the intended analysis it is important to
remember that depending on the cell line
that you're using you should be aware of
the ploidy of the cell line for your
gene target here is a simple
representation of what allylic by
discrimination to expect if there are
only two alleles for your target gene
wild-type is when there is no edit on
either allele a heterozygous edit
results from one allele being edited and
the other remaining wild-type a compound
heterozygous edit is when each allele
has a different edit and finally a
homozygous edit is when both alleles
harbour the same edit and keep in mind
that this does become more complicated
as the copy number increases as is often
the case in common tissue culture cell
lines
after you have created your Jean edited
population or clonal cell line you will
need to analyze and characterize the
edits here are some of the typical
methods used mismatch detection is a
simple PCR based assay that gives you an
estimation of in del formation although
this assay is likely an underestimation
of true gene editing due to the
specificity of the enzyme and the
sensitivity of gel analysis it is a
quick and easy way to assess editing on
your cell population
Sanger sequencing allows for
determination of the exact edit at the
sequence level and Western blotting
which is a nice confirmation of the
intended protein knockout
Co transfection in HEK 293 T cells of an
MK 2 cache 9 plasmid and a crispr RNA
targeting PPI B cells were flow sorted
based on fluorescence and plated into
single cell colonies after the cells
were expanded we characterized 42 of the
clonal line here is a summary of the 42
clonal lines that were analyzed 17
remained wild-type with no edit present
the remaining 25 edited lines consisted
of seven heterozygous edits 9 compound
heterozygous edits and nine homozygous
edits I will go into how we characterize
these edits on the next slide
here is an example of the Sanger
sequencing that was done to confirm
editing we took the PCR product and Topo
cloned it and found that in the top
example there was a compound
heterozygous edit with both alleles
having different combinations of
insertions and deletions in the bottom
example the Sanger sequencing data shows
that the same insert was present on both
alleles
we also did Western blot analysis we
selected a subset of four of the edited
clonal lines and a wild-type line as a
control we confirmed by Western blot
functional protein knockout of PPI B in
both compound heterozygous and
homozygous edited cell lines clearly
with the number of clonal lines that
were edited one could easily select a
functional knockout to expand for
further experiments
after the success of knocking out one
protein at a time we moved on to
multiplexing of guide rnas to knock out
three different gene targets in a single
transaction and varying the source of
caste 9 for these data we used both HEK
- 9 treatise and you - OS cells and had
guide RNAs targeting axl dnmt 3 B and
PPI B we also used stable integration
mrna and protein as a source of caste 9
to see if the efficiency buried based on
the caste 9 source
after delivery we diluted the cells so
that there was an average of one cell
per well and we plated two full plates
so 192 wells per condition depending on
the cell line and delivery method we saw
between 11 and 30% of the wells where
single cells grew we did notice a
difference between the two cell lines
where you two OS cells were less
amenable to single cell plating and so
had fewer clones that grew we Sanger
sequence a sub set of the wells that
grew from each condition so let's take a
look at those results
in this table we have the cell line
listed on the far left next is the cast
nine source that we used then the
characterization is shown for wild types
one two or all three genes being edited
and finally the column on the right
shows the number of clones where all
three genes are edited for every allele
based on the cell line and cast nine
source there is a distribution of the
number of clones that have one two or
three genes edited one thing to note in
our delivery of Cassadine protein
combined with three different CRISPR
RNAs all guide RNAs
were complex at the same time to make
the rnps there may be improved
efficiency if each CRISPR is complex
separately with Cassadine protein and
then combined prior to transaction the
stable expression of caste 9 improve the
overall efficiency of knock out in both
cell lines tested and showed exceptional
success in you to OS cells where there
are up to four alleles per gene and we
see that more than half of the edited
clones have all alleles edited
now moving on to our next application
which is knocking out a micro RNA
microRNAs our non-protein coding RNAs
important in gene regulation however
they differ from protein coding genes
because they are much smaller so the
sequence base to design a guide RNA is
limited additionally it is unknown if
small in Dells in the stem loop of the
micro RNA are disruptive enough to
effectively knock out the function of
the micro RNA so using to guide RNAs
flanking the micro RNA is an efficient
approach for knock out I will walk you
through this example where we generated
cast nine expressing you to OS cells
using lentiviral cast 9 and then
transfected them with a pair of CRISPR
RNAs flanking micro RNA 221 on the right
is the mismatch detection gel where we
see similar levels of gene editing for
all of the pairs tested indicating that
crispr RNA directionality and DNA target
strand did not have much of an impact on
experimental outcomes so we picked
CRISPR RNAs 2 & 4 for single colony
expansion several of which were then
randomly chosen for further analysis
here is the Sanger sequencing data and a
functional luciferase assay for four of
the clones that were selected as you can
see from the Sanger data above clonal
cell line 2 is wild-type with no edit
clonal lines 1 & 4 contain the expected
deletion from excision by both of
crispers of the crisper RNAs cutting and
clonal cell line 3 contains compound
heterozygous in Dells between the two
crispr RNA location in the graph below
you can see that the functional
conformation in a luciferase reporter
assay where again clone 2 behaves like
the wild-type and clones 1 3 & 4 behave
as knock out lines
okay so here's our last example and this
one is working in IPS cells so the idea
here is to target an essential gene
that's required for maintenance of
pluripotency in IPS cells in order to
induce differentiation with the knockout
this slide is showing the workflow that
we used for this experiment where we
made our MPs with guide RNAs targeting
pou v f1 a gene known to be expressed in
pluripotent cells and cast not Cassadine
protein at a two to one ratio which we
have found is optimal using Cassadine
protein IPS cells were electroporated
with the RMP complex and then stained
with two markers one for differentiated
cells and one that detects
undifferentiated cells
we tested five different CRISPR RNAs
targeting pou 5f1 and shown here are the
images of the untreated control and
edited IPS cells
stained with red cd4 88 and green tra
160 these are markers that detect
undifferentiated and differentiated
cells respectively you can see that as
compared to the untreated control in all
five CRISPR RNAs there is a clear shift
from red to green indicating
differentiation and confirming
functional knockout of pou v f1
as we have shown gene knockout can be
used in many different applications
including protein and non-coding RNA
knockout using clonal cell line
isolation and characterization and
additionally we looked at editing in IPS
cells showing that knockout of
pluripotency transcription factors
result in differentiation in a cell
population
alright now let's switch gears and look
at some knock in applications
for Jean knock in there are different
additional considerations including the
type of repair template that will be
used and the composition of the donor we
will show you some in-house optimization
that we have done to improve HDR
efficiencies and finally we will walk
through a few examples of fluorescently
tagging a gene of interest
here we are focused on the right-hand
side of the diagram for double-stranded
break repair for HDR
we are relying on the cell to use a
provided DNA donor template containing
homology surrounding the double strand
break and a desired insertion as a
result a precise DNA change is
introduced in the targeted location
as shown previously the same reagents
can be used for both the source of caste
9 and the guide RNA but we also need to
have a source for the donor homology the
two formats of donor DNA that I am
presenting today are single-stranded DNA
eligos or a DNA donor plasmid the
workflow is similar to knockout except
for the addition and delivery
optimization of the required repair
template
depending on the application you're
doing there are different repair
templates that should be used in general
for small insertions deletions or
replacements single-stranded DNA oligos
are used where the small insert is
surrounded by a stretch of homology on
either side on the other hand for larger
napkins plasmid repair templates are
recommended because they are more suited
for larger payloads currently more
research is being done with different
sources of donor templates but today we
will show you examples of nach in using
these two types of repair templates
here's an example of experiments where
we looked at the length of the homology
arms and the concentration of the
single-stranded donor Allah goes and the
resulting efficiencies of HD are
in the left experiment we used guide
RNAs targeting two different genes and
then varied the length of the homology
arms to determine the optimal length as
you can see in these data 30 to 40
nucleotides of homology on either end of
the insert is optimal for HDR
incorporation in the experiment on the
right we evaluated the concentration of
the donor all ago and found that between
two-and-a-half and 10 nano molar
concentration gives the most efficient
HDR integration
because we know that HDR is much less
efficient than nhej a it is important to
consider these aspects during your own
experimental optimization but these
general guidelines can be a good
starting point
now we are going to look at plasmid
donors for knockin as I just discussed
it is important to optimize any new
elements added to your HDR experiments
because of that we did an optimization
experiment in k562 cells which are known
to have high efficiencies of HDR to
assess the amount of donor plasmid that
will give the best knock in efficiencies
electroporation of cast nine protein and
crispr RNA with increasing
concentrations of a laminae egfp donor
plasmid shows correlating increase in
egfp expression up to 32 percent as
measured by flow cytometry in the images
here we see the localization of the egfp
expression in the laminae knockin
samples as expected in the nucleus and
co-localize with a nuclear stain
as a reminder from the previous section
we have had success using CRISPR cast
nine for knockout in IPS cells and we
also wanted to look at knock in of a GFP
reporter in an IPS sea line for this
experiment we Co delivered an RNP with
synthetic crispr RNA targeting sex 61
beta and an e gfp donor plasma these
images are from 72 hours after
transfection and we can see knock in of
egfp in a subset of the IPS cell
population and it is properly localized
in the endoplasmic reticulum this
localization agrees with sex 61 beta
expression
if you're interested in more information
about designing successful HDR
experiments we have another webinar that
walks through design and optimization
for HDR as well as easy to use tools for
both single stranded DNA donor oligos
and donor plasmid creation for precise
HDR at your desired location you can
find links to these tools in the webinar
library tab of this broadcast or on our
website
when using crisper cast 9 4 knock in
there are a few elements for
consideration depending on your
application the type of donor all ago
that you should use will be dependent on
the length of the sequence that you want
to knock in single-stranded DNA donor
Allah goes our best for insertions of up
to 50 bases in length whereas plasma
donors are best for larger knock ins
optimization is always important but
particularly so in HDR experiments
because of the lower efficiency of HDR
events both homology arm-length and
concentration need to be optimized for a
successful experiment we also
demonstrated precise knock in of GFP and
correct localization in both k562 s and
IPS cells all right now on to our final
and very exciting application
transcriptional activation with CRISPR a
in this section we will discuss CRISPR a
and the ability to use the CRISPR caste
9 system for gene activation
additionally we will share some
experiments that we have performed
looking at the effect of pooling CRISPR
RNAs to the same target and downstream
effects of gene activation we will also
demonstrate successful multiplexing of
CRISPR a reagents to activate multiple
genes at the same time
crisper cast 9 can be repurposed from a
gene editing tool to a transcriptional
regulation system introducing two point
mutations in the rough sea and HNH
nucleus domains shown in the top diagram
this makes the cast 9 nucleus deficient
the modified cast 9 is commonly referred
to as deactivated cast 9 or D cast 9
this non-cutting cast 9 still retains
the ability to bind to guide RNAs and to
target DNA in a sequence specific manner
D cast 9 can then be fused to one or
more transcriptional activators then
when it is guided to a genes promoter
region it can activate transcription our
editor CRISPR a activation system uses D
cast 9 vpr as described in chavez at all
2015 and guide RNAs based on the
algorithm from the wizened lab the use
of expressed single guide RNAs has
previously been published but we wanted
to evaluate activation using our
synthetic two-part guide RNA system
during testing we found that introducing
modification for nuclear resistance
improved Christopher a transcriptional
activation so all synthetic guide RNAs
include these modifications
so let's talk about some of the benefits
of CRISPR a for gene expression before
we get into the data first it enables
over expression analysis of not just
coding but non-coding genes as well
additionally the size of the transcript
does not affect the activation
efficiency for example large genes
require large expression plasmids which
are more difficult to transfer or
package than or for smaller genes also
it is easily it is easier to generate
and maintain collections of small rnas
compared to Orff's and it is highly
amenable to a raid and pooled screening
CRISPR a makes gain-of-function research
easier than ever before
similar to gene knockout experiments the
workflow for CRISPR a requires the same
two basic components the cast 9 nucleus
and the guide RNA for CRISPR a the two
options for D cast 9 vpr include either
Lenti viral particles or plasmids the
guide RNA for CRISPR a can be a
synthetic crispr RNA and tracer RNA
lentiviral sgrna particles or plasmids
the recommended workflow is to generate
stable cells and then deliver your guide
RNA following delivery several
techniques can be performed to analyze
the efficiency of activation including
Western blot rtq PCR and
immunofluorescent imaging
by looking at the level of
transcriptional activation across a
large set of genes shown in the upper
graph we observe that the level of
activation varies depending on the gene
from a few fold to thousands of fold
next we looked at the basal level of
expression of these genes before
activation which is shown in the bottom
graph and we saw that for genes that are
either not expressed or expressed at low
levels we generally observed higher
activation whereas the genes that are
more highly expressed have lower fold
activation this is similar to what has
been reported with expressed single
guide RNAs in literature it makes sense
that it is easier to activate something
that is not expressed than to boost the
expression of a gene that is already
active so knowing the current expression
level of your gene is important for
understanding the fold activation that
can be achieved
locations have shown increased
activation when multiple guide RNAs were
used per transcriptional start site so
we asked if pooling of CRISPR rnase
would increase transcriptional
activation as well
we delivered both individuals and a pool
of the four CRISPR RNAs
targeting one gene to you to OS cells
that stabili Express decaf 9v PR what we
found was that the pooled CRISPR rnase
showed activity that is either equal to
or better than the most active single
crispr RNA shown here are just two
examples of this for EGFR we see more
than a two-fold increase in activation
over any of the individuals and for pou
5f1 the activation of the pool is
equivalent to the most functional
individual crispr RNA which is number
one in this case another interesting
aspect of gene activation is looking at
the effects of genes that are downstream
in the pathway here we looked at il 1 R
2 which as you can see in the pathway
diagram on the upper left side of the
slide
when activated should inhibit the
production of il-6 and il-8
and increase the expression of Zeb 2 and
gemin to the upper right graph shows
more than ten thousandfold activation of
il 1 R 2 using a crispr RNA pool then we
detected the expression of the known
downstream targets shown in the lower
graph we indeed see inhibition of both
il-6 and il-8 and up regulation of Zeb 2
and Jemma - this is a really nice
demonstration of the utility of CRISPR a
for better understanding downstream
effects
we then evaluated targeting two genes at
the same time for activation here we
delivered CRISPR RNAs targeting either
il 1 or 2 or pou 5f one or both genes at
the same time in u 2 OS cells that
stabili Express D caste 9 v PR we looked
at the best individual crispr RNA design
number one for pou v f1 and number two
for AI l1 r2 and additionally the pool
of four designs for each gene rtq PCR
was used to determine the fold of
activation for the respective genes that
were detected on the left side of the
graph we are detecting io 1 r 2
expression and we see no activation when
the cells are transfected with a non
targeting control or with pou 5 f1 but
we see strong activation with the il 1 r
2 individual or when multiplexed with
pou 5 f1 we see an increase in the
activation with the pool for both the
singular target and the multiplex
targets also on the right side of the
graph we are now detecting pou v f1 in
these samples and are observing the same
pattern of activation with the exception
of the pool having comparable activity
to the individual which is consistent
with what we saw a few slides ago where
the activity of the pool for pou 5 f1 is
the same as the best performing
individual crispr RNA
these are images of candy
from the experiment that we just
discussed on the previous slide the non
targeting control multiplexed
individuals and the multiplex pooled
samples were fixed and stained for il 1
R 2 in red and pou 5 F 1 in green and a
nuclear dye which is shown in blue the
center image where the individual CRISPR
RNAs were delivered shows good overlap
of both genes being detected and
expressed and on the right when the
pools are used we see an increased
expression of il 1 or 2 in red which is
an agreement with the RT qpcr data from
the previous slide
so let's look at an example of CRISPR a
in IPS cells here we electroporated
plasmid for DK s 9v PR and a lentiviral
sgrna targeting pou v f1 a SC l TT n or
EGFR
detected activation with RT qPCR at 72
hours post nucleus n on the right we are
looking at the resulting transcriptional
activation because these are IPS cells
the basal expression of pou v f1 is
already high which is shown in the graph
below with a CQ value of 17 remember the
lower the CQ value the higher the
expression as you can see with the other
genes where they have higher CQ values
indicating lower expression for this
gene we are confirming what we and
others have previously observed that
when there is high basal cell expression
we don't see significant further
activation we do see good activation as
expected of the other 3 genes with ASCO
one having the highest level of
activation
had the most robust activation we again
looked at the change in expression level
of known downstream target genes in this
case DLL 1 and DLL 3 as shown in the
small pathway diagram at the upper right
hand side of the slide we observe
moderate activation of these downstream
targets as shown in the graph on the
lower right
crisper a is really an exciting new tool
for better understanding gene function a
few important takeaways include the
ability to activate a gene being
dependent on the basal cell expression
so understanding your genes expression
is important to set your expectations
for activation both individual and
pooled CRISPR RNAs work well for
activation and using pools can increase
activation levels the endogenous
activation also exhibits the expected
downstream gene activation which can
improve understanding of gene pathways
we also showed that multiplexing of
CRISPR a guide RNAs can activate
multiple genes at the same time
we have many resources available on our
website to help you design your
successful CRISPR experiments including
several application notes and
recommended reading lists for many
different applications we also have
peer-reviewed publications from our R&D
team and collaborators there is
protocols and design tools as well to
help you with your design of experiments
these can be found in the application
notes and web tools tabs of this
broadcast or on our website and lastly
since you've already shown interest in
our webinars be sure to check out our
extensive collection of other recorded
webinars covering a number of topics
that we hope will be of interest and
help you to plan your next experiments
these can all be accessed from our
website and in the webinar library tab
of this broadcast thank you for your
time today and I'm happy to take a
couple of questions with the time
remaining
Thank You Amanda for the informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar while we are
getting ready to polling questions will
appear on your screens
we really appreciate your answers to
these questions so we can follow up
appropriately with you
I would like to remind our audience that
you can submit questions by typing them
in the ask a question box type your
question into the box and hit Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
okay let's see the first question in the
queue is the guide RNA algorithm that
you presented was generated using CRISPR
rnase does it also work with single
guide RNAs yeah so during our algorithm
development we made sure to compare
different guide RNA designs and tested
the functionality between those
different formats
we tested these in multiple different
assays as well and what we found is
there's really good correlation between
the different formats of guide RNAs and
that we see good functionality when
using our algorithm across all of those
different guide RNA designs
thanks Amanda okay and on to another
question from one of our viewers what is
the method for obtaining single cell per
well for clonal isolation
sure so in the examples that we showed
today we used a few different methods in
the first examples we use facts sorting
to sort the cells into single cells
because we had that m'kay fluorescence
that we could use for sorting there are
going to be cell specific
characteristics regarding the ability of
the cell to maintain to survive after
it's been sorted that will need to be
considered when you do single cell
sorting it for Averett for example some
cells you may actually need to plate a
lot more cells to be able to maintain
enough viable cells to grow those out in
other examples we also use a dilution
method in this procedure we dilute the
cells from the edited population into an
average of less than one cell per well
and then that mixture is plated into
96-well plates and we look at how many
of those single colonies grow up into
populations thank you let's see the next
question I have here is how many gene
targets can be multiplexed for CRISPR
activation so in our testing we've
tested up to 3 genes at a time and what
we've seen is consistent with the data
that I showed today where we see
activation of all 3 genes at equivalent
levels to individual activation of those
genes we haven't pushed this further but
I certainly think that this could be
could be done and could really help with
understanding more complex pathways
where you'd like to look at multiple
genes being activated at the same time
yeah yeah great all right let's see the
next question in the queue is what is
the IPS cell line that you are working
with and how does it compare to the
human embryonic stem cell h19 line so
yeah we were using a gibdo cell line
that's derived from cd34 positive
progeny cells I'm not sure that I can
exactly say how these two lines compare
but generally anytime you're working
with the cell line in an application
that's the first time you've been doing
that as we mentioned several times you
really need to look at optimization this
includes the growth conditions the type
of reagents as well as your delivery
method we've tested about 30 or so IPS
lines in our R&D groups and we've
noticed that nucleus is typically the
best delivery system and that when those
IPS cells are cultured in an e 8 media
they tend to have a higher editing
efficiency if you want any more
specifics on this clearly reach out to
our technical support staff on on the
line or send those questions in and we'd
be happy to provide you with some of
that information
Oh excellent that's very helpful I'm
sure let's see the next question is okay
do you have crisper activation libraries
and how much do they cost so this is
something that we have been hearing a
lot of since we launched our crisper a
product line people I think are really
excited about looking at
gain-of-function using CRISPR a we are
launching CRISPR a libraries this week
as catalog items for both human and
mouse smaller custom libraries are also
available if you have your own gene list
and can be ordered with our cherry-pick
plater tool which is available on our
website in terms of price it really has
a lot to depend it depends a lot on
exactly what you're looking at doing the
amount of material that you're going to
need how large of a library it is as
well as the format of the plates that
you want is going to dictate that price
so unfortunately I can't give you exact
pricing for those for those libraries
excellent okay all right so I'm being
told that we're approaching the end of
our time allotment so let's go ahead and
answer one more question here we go
can I use your guide rnase with CPF one
or staph.aureus cast nine so we only
provide pre-designed guide RNAs for s
pyogenes cast nine however you can do
guide RNA design using our custom guide
RNA design tools for any species these
can be custom ordered you would just
select enter your own guide RNA sequence
and then enter them in and depending on
what casts you're using you would also
need to order a custom tracer to go with
that to make sure that you have all of
the right pieces involved for those
experiments alright thank you again
thank you to the audience for all the
great questions and Amanda for your
answers and I see that there are several
questions remaining in the queue if your
question was not answered someone from
our technical support team will respond
to you via email if you have further
questions but did not that you did not
submit during this broadcast please
email them to TS thermicon at horizon
discovery.com alright before we go we
would like to thank lab routes and
horizon discovery for underwriting
today's educational webcast this webcast
can be viewed on-demand through
September lab routes will alert you via
email when it's available for replay on
demand we encourage you to share the
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event until next
time goodbye